Some of the issues that arise from doing this, we talked about keeping a pile,
and it's really the system as a whole that keeps the pile and we're not going to
explicitly represent the system ourselves. There was the phrase that we had,
has been counted, and really has been counted is more a description of
a state then an action verb. Okay, so we could say count is an action verb but
has been counted as more a stative, or stative situations, so
we're going to revisit that when we get to looking at relationships. And
the phrases is set to, examine, and consists of. Well if you think about it
those are really an expression of what is the case.
So, when you examine something, you find out what is the case there.
If you examine a counter, you get back the count. These are really
ultimately going to be represented in our implementation with some kind of eq,
equality check. And so, we're going to assume that all the classes that we have
eventually come out with are going to have an equality operator associated with
them. So we're not going to explicitly model those at this time.